what is a neural network welcome to
today's lesson my name is Richard
Kirchner I am with the simply learned
team today we want to discuss the very
basics of a neural network and what that
is so what's enough for you today what
is deep learning what is artificial
neural network
how does neural network work advantages
of a neural network applications of a
neural network and the future of neural
networks let's start with a brief
history of the artificial intelligence
hello I am the human brain this one
seeking enlightenment and has sat and
meditated I am the most complex organ in
the human body and I help you to think
understand and make decisions and the
secret behind all my power is a neuron
I'll get back to that in sometime
ever since the 1950s scientists have
been trying to mimic the functioning of
a neuron and use it to build smarter
robots after a lot of trial and error
humans finally designed a computer that
can recognize human speech it was only
after 2000 that humans were able to give
birth to deep learning that was able to
see and distinguish between different
images and videos so looking at that
let's dive into what is deep learning
now your first thought might be is the
opposite of shallow learning no deep
learning
I liken to a magic box and let's go in
there just take a look as to why it's
kind of a magic box so what exactly is
deep learning these are the images of
dogs deep learning is a machine learning
technique that teaches computers to do
what comes naturally to humans learn by
example the robot gets trained with
photos as example now this is very
different than hardwiring a computer
program so that it recognizes something
it actually learns and that's where it's
a magic box because you don't really
control how it learns you control the
aspects that go in the computer comes
back it says wait I know what you are
looks at the photograph of the dog and
it's able to identify that it saw in the
images it says you are a dog woof woof
so that's an example of deep learning
you'll notice we didn't go in we'll go
into the actually how it works behind
the scenes for a neural network but
there's a bit at filling of magic and
that's where the term deep learning
comes in and that's also the term where
I like to call it a magic box you put
these things in here into the program
and it starts running the deep learning
and you
understand those settings but you don't
have to follow the exactly what's going
on in the deep learning model that
brings us to the question how does deep
learning do it
remember the neuron scientist managed to
build an artificial form of it
the powers any deep learning based
machine so let's talk about artificial
neural networks what is an artificial
neural network to understand how an
artificial neuron works we need to
understand how the real one works first
we have a dendrite input to the neuron
and you can see these little hairs that
come in and they receive information
then we have the cell body information
processing happens here so it takes all
these different dendrite and information
coming in from the different dendrites
and it looks at that information and
then you have your axon which is the
output to the neuron so there goes your
axon and you see goes all the way out
and at the very end it flanges out each
one of those little flanges connects to
the dendrite or the hairs on the next
one now let's see what an artificial
neural network looks like so an
artificial neural network we have an
input layer so that could be an array of
data each one of those white dots and
the yellow bar would represent say a
pixel in the picture then you have the
lines are connected to the hidden layers
which are your weights and they add all
those up on the hidden layers and each
one of those dots kind like a cell does
something with all the inputs and then
it puts an output into the next hidden
layer and so on into the output layer so
information processing happens here
input to the neuron output to the neuron
so you can see how they are similar we
have an input which is our yellow bar
coming in and then you like in each of
the hidden layers to being a neuron and
it passes it to the next one and so on
and then you have an output to the next
neuron or an output to the real world a
neural network is a system of hardware
and or software patterned after the
operation of neurons in the human brain
neural networks also called artificial
neural networks as a way of achieving
deep learning how does artificial neural
networks work let us find out how does
an artificial neural network work hey
Siri what is the time now it's 12:30 in
the morning thanks let's find out how
she recognizes speech here is a neural
network and the different layers on it
so we have our input layer our hidden
layers and the output layer this is the
sentence that needs to be recognized by
the
work what is the time so when it comes
in each one comes in as a pattern of
sound so what is the time first let's
consider the word what and you have WH a
T and you can see each one of those in
the sound bar probably looks a little
different than that just a
representation comes in as a different
pattern now we will split the sound wave
for the letter W into smaller segments
so we split off W and then we take W
when we analyze just W as the amplitude
is varying in the sound wave for W we
collect the values at different
intervals and form an array so we have
0.5 1.5 1.7 1.9 that might be the
different amplitudes coming in and we
feed the array of amplitudes to the
input layer so each one of those goes
into its own box on the input layer
random weights are assigned to each
interconnection between input and hidden
layer so remember uh those little lines
I said these are special weights now
we're gonna start by doing it randomly
we always start with the random key we
start with some kind of preset identical
pattern like if you set them all to
three take forever to train it and
you're less likely to get a good result
where random works really well in this
the weights are multiplied with the
inputs and a bias is added to form the
transfer function so we make a sum of
all the weights times of values so we
take point five which is your X coming
in and we're gonna multiply that by w1
w2 w3 so on and then we get to the next
level we're gonna add those together
coming in what's coming in so we add the
weight times X and there's always a bias
at it if you ever build your own neural
network don't forget to add the bias in
otherwise it tends to not work quite as
well you need that extra layer in there
to help it
weights are assigned to the
interconnection between the hidden
layers the output of the transfer
function is fed as an input to the
activation function so the output from
one hidden layer becomes the input to
the next hidden layer acoustic model
contains the statistical representation
of each distinct sound that makes a word
and so we start building these
acoustical models and as these layers
separate them out they'll start learning
what the different models are for the
different letters lexicon contains the
data for different pronunciations of
every word so we have the lexicon at the
end where we end up with the ABCD and it
identifies the different letters in
there now the term acoustic model and
the term lexicon are
Pacific to this domain the domain of
understanding speech certainly when
doing photographs and other things
you'll have different labels on here but
the process is going to be the same and
finally we get our output later
following the same process for every
word a letter the neural network
recognizes the sentence you said what is
the time so identifies a wh a T and then
identify that that's one word what is
the time and so on
it's 12:30 that way Syria can look up
the time and read it back to you so
let's look at the advantages of an
artificial neural network so gentlemen
could you tell me the advantages of an
artificial neural network it's amazing
how many times I've been in that
situation where I have to explain to the
people making the decisions in the
company it's amazing how many times have
been in that space where I have to
explain to the owner of the company what
the artificial intelligence in the
neural network actually do what are the
advantages of an artificial neural
network and what it can do for them and
how it works
so an artificial neural network outputs
aren't limited entirely by inputs and
results given to them initially by an
expert system this ability comes in
handy for robotics and pattern
recognition systems artificial neural
networks have the potential for high
fault tolerance artificial neural
networks are capable of debugging or
diagnosing a network on their own very
common use these days is to go through
all the log files and sort them out
thousands of log files if you're in
working as an admin nonlinear systems
have the capability of finding shortcuts
to reach computational expensive
solutions so we see this in banking
where by hand they have an Excel
spreadsheet and then they start building
codes around that Excel spreadsheet in
over 20 years they might build a
repertoire of all these functions and
the neural network comes up with the
same answers done in days weeks or even
a month for a huge bank so let's take a
look a little bit more because I
mentioned a couple applications of
artificial intelligence there but let's
dig deeper into the applications of
artificial intelligence let's look at
some of the real life this is stuff
going on right now in our world that
we're in that such an exciting time with
the neural networks and the machine
learning and the artificial intelligence
development so let's take a little look
at some of the current applications
going on in real life and you can use
your imagination to
for some new ones that we don't have
listed here because it's so limitless
the amount of applications that are
being worked on right now or being
implemented handwriting recognition
neural network is used to convert
handwritten characters into digital
characters that the system can recognize
stock-exchange prediction if you've ever
worked with stock exchange which i have
it is so fickle to track I mean it is
really hard to understand there are many
factors that affect the stock market
neural network can examine a lot of
factors and predict the prices on a
daily basis helping the stockbrokers so
right now it's still intro phase where
it helps them and they really have to
look closely at it when you realize that
we generate over three terabytes a day
just from the stock exchange here in the
United States that's a lot of data to
dig through and you have to sort it out
before you even start focusing on even
one stock traveling salesman problem it
refers to finding the optimal path to
travel between all cities in an area
neural network helps solve the problem
providing higher revenue at a minimal
cost Logistics is huge just the
logistics that we talk about salesmen
traveling from town to town logistics
are used by Amazon Amazon loves to ship
their packages and they have empty space
on their trucks
so they'll pre ship packages and fill
that empty space on who they think will
buy it saves them a lot of time and
people are a lot happier because they
get that tomorrow instead of having to
wait three weeks image compression idea
behind data compression neural network
is to store encrypt and recreate the
actual image again so we can optimize
our compression and data images are the
biggest one but it's using all kinds of
data wonderful application to save hard
drive and to optimize being able to read
it back out again those are just a few
and like I said use your mind to dig
deeper and let's take it even further
we're gonna go step further here and
let's look at the future of deep
learning here we are that's not me thank
goodness a wonderful person there
reading her crystal ball I'll tell you
what I see in the future more
personalized choices for users and
customers all over the world I certainly
like that when I go in there and
whatever online ordering system starts
referring stuff to me local company here
where I live that uses this where you
can take a picture and it starts looking
for what you want based on your picture
so if you see a couch you like starts
looking for furniture like that or
clothes
I think it's mainly clothing
hyper-intelligent virtual assistants
will make life easier if you played with
Google assistant or Siri or any of those
you can see how they're slowly evolving
and they're just now getting over that
hump where our virtual assistant can do
all kinds of things even pre write your
email response for you new forms of
algorithm for learning methods would be
discovered
there's always something rolling out
they've had some really cool research in
this area again this stuff is such a
we're just in the infant stage of
artificial intelligence and neural
networks and actually applying them to
the real world wonderful time to jump in
neural networks will be a lot faster in
the future neural network tools will be
embedded in every design surface we
already see that that you can buy a
little mini neural network that plugs
into a really cheap processing board or
into your laptop so the hardware
starting to come out that goes right in
there where you can dump it on there and
that makes it also faster so because
it's on the hardware instead of the
software side neural networks will be
used in the field of medicine
agriculture physics discoveries just
everything you can imagine we see this
today where it's going from a PhD
student in medicine trying to understand
t-cells and understand the statistic
analysis of that to cure people to help
keep them healthy to help find out how
we heal to something that anybody can go
access and process the data on they're
working on shared data systems this
concept of it being used in these
different fields and these different
domains is huge the world is wide open
for anybody jumping out there to start
exploring them and start learning neural
networks so with that I want to thank
you for joining us today for more
information visit
www.cannainsider.com/careers
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here